es una palabra que podría tener fuertes
consecuencias así que a diferencia de
Ucrania Señor las fuerzas
estadounidenses los hombres y las
mujeres estadounidenses defenderían a
Taiwán en caso de una invasión china así
al mencionar el apoyo militar directo de
Washington rompe con la doctrina
estadounidense hacia Taiwán denominada
ambigüedad estratégica indica que
Washington ayudará a la isla a
defenderse en caso de Invasión china
pero sin especificar si esto implicaría
la intervención militar de Estados
Unidos Beijing no esperó para contestar
este lunes acusó a Estados Unidos de
violar su compromiso de no apoyar la
independencia de Taiwán y de amenazar la
estabilidad del estrecho
nunca toleraremos Ninguna actividad que
tenga como objetivo dividir el país y
nos reservamos el derecho de tomar todas
las medidas necesarias Nadie debe
subestimar la resuelta determinación del
pueblo chino y su fuerte oportunidad
para defender la soberanía nacional y la
integridad territorial no se enfrentan a
los 1.400 millones de chinos Estados
Unidos reconoció en 1979 la política de
una sola china Lo que incluía a Taiwán
pero a principios de agosto la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes Nancy pelosi visitó La
Isla lo que enfureció a Beijing en
represalia China llevó a cabo enormes
ejercicios militares acercándose a pocos
kilómetros de la costa taiwanesa unas
tensiones que resurgen en momentos en
que el senado de Estados Unidos estudia
entregar ayuda militar a Taiwán más de
4000 millones de dólares en defensa para
los próximos años